[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec la une les
inquiétudes des agriculteurs à cause de
la sécheresse celle ci touche une bonne
partie de la france et menace certaines
récoltes exemple dans la somme avec ou
et aux tv la chaîne de la voix du nord
dès le début de ce journal il s'appelle
le thé les eaux et il est désormais le
plus long téléphérique urbain de france
ce mode de transport plus écolo et
pratique est en service depuis quelques
jours à toulouse à l'action de via
occitanie nous fera voyager à bord la
réalité et la fiction toujours plus
proche un espace de 1000 m² est dédié à
la pratique pour le moins sportive du
jeu vidéo à battre virtuellement des
zombies ou ses partenaires et bien c'est
possible grâce à un casque un reportage
devient 95 à suivre dans cette édition
et puis en toute fin de journal moselle
tv nous emmènera prendre du bon temps
sur l'eau avec une balade musicale et
historique un avant goût de l'été pour
nous tous
quand le mois de mai ressemble au mois
de juillet vous l'avez sûrement constaté
chez vous les températures sont très
élevées pour la saison plus de 30 degrés
cette semaine sur une partie de la
france une vague de chaleur doublée d'un
manque criant de pluie dans la somme
vous allez le voir pas une goutte n'est
tombé depuis plus d'un mois conséquence
les sols s'assèche et les cultures de
printemps décroche mettra vos carottes
et même céréales pen a poussé de quoi
inquiéter les agriculteurs les
explications de jérémy où on pour vous
et vos tv la chaîne de la voix du nord
regarder
armé de sa bêche simon vient inspecter
ses terres dans une dizaine de jours
l'agriculteur devrait y semer des
haricots mais la sécheresse pourrait
bien contrecarrer ses plans donc là on
voit que 5 cm de profondeur il ya plus
de fraîcheur du tout l'humidité est
indispensable pour que la pour que la
graine puisse puisse germer donc là
c'est dans cette situation-là
l'irrigation elle sera au sras
indispensables comme beaucoup
d'agriculteurs sinon subi de plein fouet
l'absence de pluviométrie pas une goutte
ne s'est abattue sur les culture picarde
depuis plus d'un mois résultat carottes
betteraves ou même céréales peine à se
développer seule solution pour assurer
les rendements faire tourner les canons
d'arrosage
c'est déjà problématique en soi parce
que cette sécheresse elle arrive au
printemps s'il n'y a pas de fraîcheur
dans le sol le sirpa d'humidité dans le
sol la graine ne peut pas géré mais
voilà il n'y a pas le choix et de toute
façon pour tout ce qui est culture de
légumière fin comme la carotte etc c'est
s'aider culture où il est indispensable
d'avoir l'eau pour sécuriser de la
culture pour faire installer
l'irrigation sur ces parcelles simon a
investi plus de 120000 euros une somme
que tous les professionnels ne peuvent
débourser à quelques kilomètres de là
pierre constate lui aussi l'impact du
manque d'eau sur ces betteraves faute de
pouvoir arroser ses cultures il joue la
montre en attendant la pluie on va
toujours dit que un binage vaut deux
arrosages puisque outre le fait de de
travail et l'intérêt est donc le
détruire les mauvaises herbes ça permet
aussi de briser la croûte de surface qui
s'est formé avec le temps sec le fait
d'ailleurs el sol en surface va permet
d'économiser un outil peu de la réserve
en eau du sol seulement 4 météo depuis
le début de l'année la somme ne compte
que huit jours de pluie
voilà tout à fait autre chose nous vous
en parlions dans une précédente édition
les français peinent à renouveler leurs
pièces d'identité al'approche des
vacances d'été en cause les confinements
successives mais aussi la réduction du
nombre de mairies qui proposent ce
service la face à cette situation un
plan d'urgence est déployé au niveau
national exemple dans la sarthe avec ce
reportage d'anthony python de la
rédaction de lmtv sarthe
refaire ses papiers n'a jamais été aussi
long en sarthe impossible d'obtenir un
rendez-vous avant fin août voire
septembre
tiens septembre pour les rendez vous
depuis le mois de novembre on ne fait
que ça avant toutes les mers il faisait
maintenant nous ne sommes plus que 19
ans art allait faire donc
automatiquement à tous les rendez-vous
s'accumulent s'il n'y a plus que 19
mairie qui prennent en charge ces
demandes c'est parce que désormais il
faut passer par un dispositif de recueil
un appareil qui permet de collecter les
empreintes il y en a 29 ans art pour 354
commune mais pour expliquer ces délais
interminables un autre paramètre doit
être pris en compte les habitants
pendant deux ans n'ont pas voyagé donc
ont mis de côté le fait de refaire leurs
passeports et leurs craintes pour venir
récupérer sa pièce d'identité pour un
temps à peu près huit semaines une fois
est passé en mairie c'est à la
préfecture du mans que toutes les
demandes de la région pays de la loire
centre était déjà 180 3165 demande entre
le 1er janvier de cette année et début
mai on est à des progressions de
demandes de plus de 50% pour les cartes
nationales d'identité de plus de 90%
pour les passeports six personnes
supplémentaires ont été recrutés à la
préfecture pour faire face à cet afflux
est un plan d'urgence nationale et
déployé une enveloppe de 10 millions
d'euros et 400 dispositifs de recueil
seront répartis sur toute la france
outre mesure qui peut s'avérer utile
pour les étudiants les cartes d'identité
et les passeports expiré depuis moins de
cinq ans sont valides pour les examens
de mai et de juin
l'émission face aux territoires étaient
diffusés ce jeudi matin sur tv5 monde un
numéro spécial consacré à la nomination
d'elizabeth borne à matignon l'ancien
ministre des transports de la transition
écologique et du travail dispose pour
elle d'une expérience précieuse regardez
cet extrait de face aux territoires
sa dernière grande émission politique eh
bien c'était ici chez nous ici même à
face aux territoires c'était le 10
février dernier elle était notre invité
écouter ce qu'elle a déclaré sur sa
relation avec ségolène royal si vous
avez des nouvelles de ségolène royal
dont vous avez dirigé le cabinet a nommé
deux grands pas de nouvelles agences
pouvoir donner vous ne venez pas de
contacts n'ont pas vraiment de contacts
non je pense qu'on est pas tout à fait
d'accord sur beaucoup de sujets bruno
cautrès fair gattegno donc les contacts
sont rompues ça mérite de la franchise
effectivement comme dégradation alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on voit
elisabeth bord qui que ça amuse aussi
votre votre question est visible en
tranches voilà les franches visiblement
leurs relations de travail puisque
elisabeth bonne à travailler sous
l'autorité de ségolène royal n'a pas dû
17 beaucoup de bons souvenirs
l'émission face au territoire consacré à
la nomination d'elizabeth bornes
première ministre est à voir ou à revoir
sur les sites internet des partenaires
de l'émission ouest france nice matin et
vingt minutes tout à fait autre chose
direction toulouse à présent dans ce
journal pour y découvrir un moyen de
transport étonnant le plus grand
téléphérique urbain de france télé
haussé son nom connecte depuis quelques
jours deux points de la ville rose situé
en hauteur avantage de ce transport le
gain de temps et la réduction de
l'impact environnemental
pour son lancement le déplacement en
téléphérique long de 3 km et est gratuit
et stéphanie forgeois pour vyas
occitanie en a profité et est monté à
bord regardez je me suis dit un
téléphérique en pleine ville j'avais
jamais vu et franchement c'était super
c'est magnifique a super la
impressionnant quand ça décolle en soi
un bon ski le plus long téléphérique
urbain de france vient officiellement
d'ouvrir ses portes au public télé au
permet de rejoindre l'oncopôle au départ
de l'université paul sabatier en
seulement 10 minutes ce week end le
trajet gratuit une belle occasion pour
les toulousains de découvrir cette
nouvelle attraction
je trouve que c'est bien et on voit bien
la vue mais c'est
un peu comme une attraction c'est
impressionnant c'est l'impression d'être
dans un manège
pour essayer avec le petit pour essayer
c'est un parc d'attractions aujourd'hui
en fait ouais c'est un peu ça ouais je
n'utiliserai pas souvent au quotidien
mais voilà sur ça je vois sa pelouse la
rentabilité de ce nouveau moyen de
transport ne sera visible que dans
quelques mois mais les usagers espèrent
que tu es léo va désengorger le
périphérique toulousain oui moi je pense
que ça fera pas tout mais bon c'est déjà
une première chose pour avancer dans la
meilleure circulation sur toulouse
aurait pu espérer que ça va désengorger
le périphérique ça va inciter les gens à
prendre les transports en commun je vais
le prendre pour aller à rangueil où
c'est très bien je me garderais là et
puis je descendrai un téléphérique à
partir de ce lundi le trajet devient
payant comme pour le métro et le bus le
ticket coûte 1 euro 60 ans et validé
votre titre avant de monter à bord
c'est une première en france un
établissement de santé et déconstruit et
non démoli pour laisser la place
d'ailleurs un nouvel établissement vous
allez le voir dans les vosges une
maternité est en travaux et sera
remplacé dans quelques mois par un
centre lourd de dialyse si cela peut
sembler a priori ordinaire la méthode
l'est moins ainsi tous les matériaux qui
pourront l'être seront réutilisées un
symbole de ce que l'on appelle
l'économie circulaire précision
d'anthony sap et de anne didier pour
vosges télévision
son activité a été transféré l'année
passée dans le nouvel hôpital d'epinal
la maternité arc-en-ciel de la ligne
bleue laissera bientôt la place à ce que
l'on appelle un centre lourd de dialyse
avec ces consultations de néphrologie un
service de soins de suite et de
réadaptation cardiovasculaire
sachant que l'établissement reçoit
chaque semaine 150 personnes souffrant
d'insuffisance rénale chronique et 60
nouveaux patients chaque année le nombre
de postes de dialyse sera ainsi doublé
passant de 24 à 48 ans box individuels
dessiner le d'être confortable qu'on
photo am déjà pour les patients mais ce
sera pour la partie dialyse vous savez
qu'un patient égaliser trois fois par
semaine à raison de quatre à six heures
donc ils ont chacun un espace de vie une
chambre personnelle et le site devrait
également être plus agréable pour le
personnel soignant mais avant cela il
faudra passer par quelques mois de
travaux et pour ce faire le pôle
louis-pasteur santé qui gère la clinique
a décidé non pas de démolir le bâtiment
mais de le déconstruire pour récupérer
tous les matériaux qui pouvaient l'être
les revendre et réduire ainsi les allers
retours vers la déchetterie une idée qui
a encore du mal à faire son chemin c'est
d'ailleurs ici une première en france
pour un établissement de santé ça s'est
jamais vu parce que souvent ne comprends
pas le raisonnement du réemploi est donc
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on fait de la
demo de la démolition traditionnel alors
que là l'objet c'est justement de
déposer à l'envers du construit pour
pouvoir ré employés ailleurs pour
l'instant tout part à la matériauthèque
de l'association amis et qui est mis en
vente aux particuliers qui souhaitent
préparer chez lui mais à moindre coût et
si l'on parle peu de déconstruction
c'est aussi parce que très peu de
professionnels du bâtiment sont capables
de le faire l'entreprise spinalienne
d'insertion reval presque a donc
décroché le marché avec une dizaine de
ses salariés qu'ils apprennent le métier
tout en travaillant ce qui leur ouvre
forcément de belles perspectives
d'avenir c'est un marché privé donc ça
aussi c'est une première pour vale
presse effectivement s'apercevra que
depuis un mois un mois et demi on fait
souvent appel à nous dans la
déconstruction les travaux devraient
durer quelques mois pour une ouverture
du centre en décembre ou janvier
prochain coût global de l'opération
environ huit millions et demi d'euros
matériel médical compris lui aussi est
un chantier unique à limoges la
préservation des arbres et des espaces
verts est au coeur des préoccupations
locales les services de la ville ont
travaillé pendant deux ans au sauvetage
d'un séquoia posé sur un bâtiment
destiné à la démolition l'arbre a fait
l'objet de toutes les attentions et est
désormais sauver son histoire vous est
racontée par alain drouho pour la
rédaction de 7 à limoges
nous connaissons cet arbre depuis
toujours ou presque a plus de 50 ans il
fait parfois s'arrêter les promeneurs
avenue du maréchal foch appuyé depuis
plus de 15 ans sur un bâtiment annexe de
l'école du quartier voué à la démolition
le séquoia était en danger après deux
ans d'observation et de soins il est
tiré d'affaires et en sécurité pour ce
faire on a dû mettre l'arbre avec un
était pour pouvoir sécuriser le chantier
afin que les gens puissent travailler
tranquillement et en sécurité pour
abattre le bâtiment il a une forme
particulière c'est un séquoia d'andrew
pendule sommes donc sa forme qui pousse
à l'horizontale elle est normale et
pendant la période d'observation l'arbre
a même été scannées pour bien comprendre
son organisation et avant la possibilité
de le modélisé dans son environnement ça
permet en fait de mettre à un instant t
la réalité de l'ouvragé dans l'ensemble
de sa géométrie donc par exemple vous
pouvez pour commencer un dossier par
exemple
de réhabilitation ou d'extension on va
prendre on va scanner l'existant ce qui
va nous permettre d'avoir en 3d un déjà
la volumétrie réel dans son ensemble au
moment t où on réalise le scan l'arbre
est réputé anti fragile c'est à dire
qu'il va s'améliorer en s'adaptant tout
au long de sa vie
l approche à grands pas la saison
estivale elle débutera dans quelques
semaines et comme chaque année vous
serez des millions à passer vos vacances
d'été sur les côtes hexagonal alors pour
assurer votre sécurité la surveillance
des plages a commencé sur le littoral
aquitain notamment à lacanau durant les
week-ends et les jours fériés une
surveillance renforcée cette année par
la mise en place d'une nouvelle
signalétique le drapeau bleu fameux et
remplacé par un drapeau bicolore pour
délimiter les zones de baignade
surveillées images et propos recueillis
par aurélie challes vaut pour télé 7 la
chaîne du groupe sud ouest on a choisi
ses couleurs là puisque en fait on s'est
rapproché des couleurs qui existait déjà
dans les autres pays à l'international
on était l'un des derniers pays à
utiliser des couleurs qui était
différente et c'est pour ça qu'on a
voulu unifier tout ça pour que bah déjà
les touristes étrangers puissent s'y
retrouve et qu'on soit aussi nous dans
une démarche constructive
et évidemment sur la plage cet été vous
vous équiperez probablement de votre
plus beau maillot de bain pour bronzer
et vous détendre masculin ou féminin ce
vêtement n'échappe pas à la tendance éco
responsable en corse une jeune créatrice
a lancé il y a quelques années sa marque
de maillots de bain fabriqué à partir de
filets de pêche recyclé objectif
proposer des pièces tendances tout en
respectant l'environnement explication
de la créatrice lors d'une séance photos
aux questions d'arnaud baresi et
dangereux si ni devient télévisée en
corse bien sûr le concept c'est l'éco
responsabilité je fabrique les maillots
de bain et réactive aux héros aussi avec
un tissu italien qui est de grande
qualité et qui est fabriqué à partir de
filets de pêche et léché océanique qui
sont recyclées régie ça me tenait à
coeur de trouver un tissu
éco-responsable et d'avoir une démarche
soucieuse de l'environnement dans une
chaîne de production assez courte c'est
la marque qui a créé sa qui se charge de
récolter tous ces déchets dans les fonds
marins et ensuite de commencer le
processus de recyclage leur régénération
plus d'autonomie pour les élèves et plus
de sérénité pour les adultes la cantine
en mode de self services débarquent à
l'école primaire alors d'ordinaire
réservé aux collégiens et lycéens ce
mode de restauration est devenu le
quotidien d'enfants du cp au cm2 dans la
loire les élèves apprennent ainsi à
gérer le repas ou à trier leurs déchets
pour la collectivité c'est aussi la
promesse d'une meilleure efficacité lors
du service explications et reportage de
céline ersilia pour la chaîne tn 7 dans
la loire
11h30 les élèves des écoles primaires
privées et publiques de la fouillouse se
retrouve dans la cour devant leur
restaurant scolaire premier réflexe
vérifier l'ordre de passage des classes
et très vite le service commence la
salle de cantine a été aménagé en self
où les enfants sont autonomes ne leur
conviennent se servir comme un plateau
une entrée lors dessert ils sont servis
en plat chaud un système qui a été bien
accueilli par les élèves et bien c'est
mieux parce que l'on n'est pas obligé
d'attendre et où s'écoule on est
mischa barton on soit sûr qu'on veut ou
pas mais pop chinoise et de lord si on
peut commencer par le désert un peu et
pendant que certains déguste d'autres
attendent leur tour dans une ambiance de
mj c'est un animateur est présent pour
occuper les élèves avec des jeux de la
lecture ou bien des activités sportives
et trois jours sur quatre en musique le
nouveau système promet des enfants plus
détendu donc voila voila différente des
enfants qui sont plus autonome
moi moi stressé mois sur la rapidité
pourtant pour le personnel que pour les
enfants on avait une salle qui était
rempli avec 100 jusqu'à plus de 100
enfants beaucoup de bruits de service
qui devait être organisée mais vraiment
au corps nos c'est à dire il fallait pas
dépasser d'une minute donc c'était
c'est reposant pour personne avec ce
système la cantine ne peut gérer 200
couverts et la capacité pourrait monter
jusqu'à 400 de quoi prévoir
l'augmentation de la population sur
plusieurs années et proposer une cantine
à l'ambiance festive
voilà restons à table dans ce grand jt
des territoires avec la découverte d'un
ustensile de cuisine qui pourrait bien
vous être utile si vous êtes fan de
pizza ou de tarte le granby coupe vous
le voyez à l'écran est une double
roulette qui vient de remporter la
médaille d'or dans le fameux concours
lépine catégorie nature et bien-être
grâce aux deux roulettes de cette
invention fini la résistance des bords
de vos tartes préféré écouter ce qu'on
peut les précisions de son inventeur un
habitant de l'aube il répond aux
questions de willy briard du journal
l'est éclair regardez les prêts mais
qu'elle voulait tafisa quand on veut
couper d'un plat à tarte avec on n'a
jamais avoir la croûte dans le coin le
trottoir
du coup la petite lame est là pour venir
sectionné la coupe dans les coins en
plus de ça il ya un petit décapsuleur
quel cachet juste ici on va l'opposer à
l'envers pour passer hier la table tout
est en méthane jeu corps et âmes axa
s'est fait sur lyon les lames sont en
acier inoxydable c'est pas sûr tiers et
les petits réflexes sont ici sont faits
dans les ardennes c'est l'inox j'ai même
intégré la notice directement un
packaging pour faire des économies de
papier
voilà une bien belle invention à la fois
pratique et éco-responsable donc ouvrant
une page sports est désormais plus
exactement du sport pour tous avec des
pratiques adaptées à des personnes en
situation de handicap en savoie toute
une après midi était consacré à
l'expérience d'activités tels que le
basket ou le foot-fauteuil l'occasion de
démontrer que le sport peut être quoi
qu'il arrive facteur de partage et
d'émotion un sujet de lukas rock pour la
chaîne 8 mont blanc sur place
oublié sa différence pour profiter des
émotions transmises par le sport en
s'adonnant à la sarbacane au tennis de
table ou encore aller ce crime 80 jeunes
savoyards en situation de handicap on
profitait une journée de découverte
multisports
cet événement co organisé par le comité
handisport et le comité de sport adapté
de savoie a pour but de faire sortir les
jeunes de leur quotidien et vu le
sourire de mélanie et ses copines le
pari semble réussi
[Musique]
les meuniers
aujourd'hui
du côté du mur d escalade
on retrouve les mêmes sourires qu'ils
soient valides ou non le sport permet de
véhiculer des émotions recherché par
tout le monde c'est les mêmes vertus que
pour le monde n'ose rien c'est ses
bienfaits du sport que ce soit pour le
corps pour l'esprit la sociabilisation
devra de partager une activité avec aux
personnes développer la motricité
ancien champion de france de natation
handisport
julien grange en pratique aujourd'hui le
football fauteuil en contribuant à son
épanouissement personnel le sport lui a
permis de surmonter son handicap le
plein pendant six à se faire plaisir et
faire plaisir que tout handicap on peut
faire du sport tu chacun trouve trop son
plaisir et et voilà tout temps oubliée
voilà de surpasser handicapés et d'être
heureux dans sa peau et qui sait
peut-être bien que pour ces jeunes la
découverte du jour deviendra vocation de
demain
cela ne vous aura sûrement pas échappé
l'univers du jeu vidéo se développe
désormais de plus en plus dans la
réalité virtuelle en ile-de-france deux
espaces dédiés 2 500 m² chacun
permettent à des joueurs de rentrer dans
la peau d'un personnage de jeu vidéo
grâce à un casque une expérience unique
qui connaît un franc succès depuis son
lancement il ya un an un sujet de
michael joly pour la rédaction devient
95 dans l'oise
[Musique]
gérant côté hockey muni de cette arme
factice d'un casque sur le visage il
d'un ordinateur dans le dos sylvain
s'apprête à rentrer dans l'arène virtuel
d'un jeu vidéo il va y affronter une
autre équipe de 5 joueurs grâce à la
réalité virtuelle ce hangar va se
transformer en zone de guerre comme vous
voyez sur le casque du coup il ya de
petites caméras devant qui vont servir
de capteurs pour du coup calibre est
directement la zone au niveau des qr
codes qui sont affichés au sol et sur
les murs donc c'est grâce à ça que les
cas ce que mon pouvoir visualiser la
zone est différent et fier des joueurs
les non joueurs directement et après une
demi-heure de jeu le novice et séduisent
la demi heure
c'est fait en cinq minutes on avait
l'impression et
c'est très très immersif et c'était
super cool c'est vraiment très bon
implantée à beauchamp cette salle de jeu
dispose de deux champs de bataille
virtuel de 500 mètres carrés chacun
plusieurs modes de jeu sont proposés
bataille entre équipes ou contre des
zombies
capture de drapeau ou encore chacun pour
soi franchise d'une société française
lancée en 2018 cette halle de jeu a
ouvert au printemps 2021 est la base moi
je suis pas du tout gamer c'est mes deux
associés qui sont plus gamer que mois
après quand tu te lances dans un projet
faut bien essayer hélas le fait d'avoir
essayé bah ouais samassa m'a séduit que
le jeu vidéo était vraiment marrant et
c'est un truc
auquel on tient et un an après son
ouverture
l'établissement compte une clientèle
régulière comme ses joueurs qui
pratiquent depuis plusieurs mois et
participe à des compétitions c'est
vraiment un jeu mais physique c'est à
dire là c'est vraiment comme si c'est
moi qui étais dans le call of duty donc
bah c'est ça qui m'a fait j'ai adoré on
voit nos amis on bouge j'ai perdu 6
kilos
pour une demi heure de jeu il faut
compter 10 9 euros et pour 89 euros par
mois un pass illimité en semaine est
également proposé les jeux peut être
pratiqué à partir de 12 ans
c'est un univers méconnu mais qui
fascine autant qu'il intrigue celui des
croupiers de casino ces professionnels
des jeux avaient rendez vous à monaco
évidemment pour s'affronter entre
meilleurs spécialistes européens une
compétition à laquelle ont pris part 22
pays durant deux jours au sein du
célèbre casino de monte-carlo technique
aisance comportement les 40 groupes y
ont été scrutés deux jours durant parmi
eux deux membres de la délégation
monégasque écouter leurs impressions
devant les caméras de monaco info
l'important c'est de pouvoir ce
challenge et avec d'autres pays se
confronter aux autres
voilà les points forts et les points
faibles de chaque pays et en tirer le
meilleur c'est très enrichissant déjà de
les côtoyer de voir tout le monde autour
d'eux sera comme ça de tous les pays et
voilà de honnêtement je pense que le mot
c'est fier c'est hier
que des riez vous d'une balade sur l'eau
tout en musique et en histoire pour
conclure cette édition du grand jt c'est
le programme pour le moins alléchant
d'un capitaine qui promet le dépaysement
de ses hôtes lors d'une traversée sur la
moselle une occasion de découvrir le
patrimoine local son histoire sa faune
mais aussi sa flore une escapade
poétique pour l'été et à l'heure de
l'apéritif les premières sorties ont
débuté et chloé gaillard de moselle tv a
pu suivre l'une d'entre elles regarder
sur le quai des régates à metz une
dizaine d'aventuriers s'est retrouvé
pour deux heures de balade sur la
moselle dans une ambiance feu de camp le
capitaine ou robbie s'apprête à lever
l'ancré sur sa petite calédonie s'il
peut t'il commuter et patrimoine et
nature sont originaires de la région et
j'ai redécouvert metz comme un touriste
et je me suis rendu compte qu'on avait
la chance d'avoir une ville magnifique
avec un riche patrimoine avec une nature
exceptionnelle
à la barre le chef de bord se plaît à
faire découvrir l'histoire la nature et
le patrimoine local un moment apprécié
par les navigateurs fait autre chose qui
passe là sur sept sur sept rivières il
ya ya de la poésie de la lumière
il ya il ya de la vie c'est la diversité
en passer c'est magnifique quoi en plus
de déguster un verre de vin de moselle
et quelques amuse gueule en
court-circuit le petit comité se délecte
d'un concert acoustique intime
[Musique]
le partage et la convivialité sont les
maîtres mots de cet instant si les
marins d'eau douce profits dans toute
sérénité c'est en partie grâce à leur
embarcation solaire on est autonome a
obligé de charger à quai avec lequel
août à l'électricité on peut recharger à
quai mais du juste avec les panneaux
solaires il est autonome on peut alors
on va naviguer les batteries se sont
chargés toute la journée on est autonome
de quoi admirer et écouter la cité
messine depuis ses parties les plus
sauvages jusqu'à la vieille ville
illuminée fièrement gardé par son
célèbre temple je le conseillerai à des
touristes évidemment mais surtout à des
locaux parce que on voit jamais la ville
de la même façon quand on la découvre
sur l'eau cette escapade poétique est à
savourer tout au long de l'été chaque
mardi soir une occasion d'admirer un
beau coucher de soleil ou un envol de
signes
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]